hi everyone thank you so much for
joining our presentation today
titled high throughput low-cost
transcriptome profiling
with the applied biosystems clarium go
screen assay
it's my pleasure to introduce you to
anthony schweitzer
anthony is the principal scientist and
director of bioinformatics for
expression microarrays at thermo fisher
scientific
for anthony's complete biography please
visit the tab at the top of your screen
and if there are any questions during
this presentation we encourage you to
submit
those in the q a box anthony will
address your questions following the
presentation
please join me in welcoming anthony
schweitzer i'll now turn the
presentation
over to him thank you maggie
welcome everybody thank you for joining
us today uh today we're going to talk
about
uh rna gene expression or
transcriptomics but specifically
today we're going to talk about a high
throughput low cost system we call
go screen and what's really great about
this system or platform is that the
all-in price point per sample
is 50 or 50 euros uh depending on what
location you're at
but basically it allows you to do
thousands and thousands of samples
reading out a transcriptome profile
there's very flexible sample input you
can use either purified rna
or this has actually been designed to
work with direct lysis
which you'll see is quite convenient for
people who are doing
screening hit profiling this application
is currently only available through
partnerships
with two different service providers
that we've negotiated with
so this is not run inside your lab
however you would send samples to the
service provider and they would run it
for you
now just to orient you as to
uh how this platform compares to other
micro array solutions that we offer
if you look at this slide over here on
the far left uh we have our
discovery solution which is the clarion
d
solution the d stands for deep and this
allows you to get a very deep view of
the transcriptome this is a microarray
that can read over six
million different probes uh you can look
across every well annotated gene in our
transcriptome
and many uh unannotated genes or content
we call speculative
the resolution of this particular
microarray is exon resolution so it's
like casting a very wide net
to do discovery types of work especially
if you're looking for biomarkers
when we move into more uh profiling and
screening
people tend to focus on well-annotated
genes things that you have to find in
the refseq
database of the hugo pathways database
and for these applications we have the
clarion s
as well as the product we're going to
talk to you today about which is this
ghost green product
now these assays essentially will look
at well-annotated genes
and give you essentially a pathway level
analysis of what's happening
if you would look in the literature what
people publish on most people
publish on well-annotated genes
essentially it's only
uh if people really want to do either
discovery that they would go and use
something like clarium d
versus what we're talking about today
which is more profiling
of course to continue the rna solutions
that we offer there's also verification
solutions and these are panels
essentially
that people would use for routine
clinical testing
research things like tacman and open
array
uh and any of the uh amplicip panels
that exist out there
for thermal fissure now the product that
we're talking about
uh today this goes green product is
actually a 384 peg plate
that you can see down here being pointed
to by this red arrow
on the human version of this particular
peg plate we can fit
what is essentially 20 000 human genes
and within that 20 000 human genes you
get essentially
all of the genes in the gene ontology
database
everything in wikipedia pathway any of
the biomarker associated genes that are
out there
if you're if you're used to looking at
different panels uh by other platforms
things like immunology markers or
inflammation markers
they all exist already in this
collection of 20 000 genes
so again you don't have to sacrifice
what you're looking at
when you can look at 20 000 different uh
gene expression events using this
particular platform
of course we keep other content on here
as well we have
housekeeping genes gender length genes
which are useful for doing quality
control of samples
and in this human go screen play we
actually have also
included some human viral content now
that content is often used to actually
set up and develop a screening
application within
a compound pharma screening that would
be done
by by the pharmaceutical companies it's
conceivable that you could
measure a viral content
with this uh say if you're screening
human samples
however that's not the intent of this
content this content was actually there
to monitor the the viral load used in
the screen itself
now much like human we've also developed
a version of this array
on rat and for that we have the clarium
ghost green rat
and here we have 21 597 rat genes and
again
much like the human version or human
counterpart of this we focused on the
well-annotated genes
for rats now one interesting
interesting thing about rat is that most
of the companies out there
are using uh two one of two different
versions
of the the rat uh species here
um we've done here empirical probe
selection
with samples using the hanwistar
rat as well as the sprague dolly
assembled genome
and this was important because if you go
to your databases
and map essentially probes and develop
gene models
that is currently all being done with
the spread dolly and
what was important for us to do is to
make sure that any snips
or genetic variation in the hand with
star would be accounted for in this
particular design
and so we're very careful to do that
basically if you're doing any kind of
uh wrap models and screening with them
this this is the array that you would
want to use
now the go in in clarion go screen
is actually referring to the gene
ontology resource and this is a very
important database
for many of our pharmaceutical partners
they essentially are able to break out
the gene content of our transcriptomes
and use this resource
to get information in terms of the
cellular components the biological
processes
and the molecular functions of the genes
that we've represented
on on these particular microarrays
now the application that
is most used today for these ghost
screen products is
pharma secondary compound library
screening which is essentially hit
profiling
so what happens is these pharmaceutical
companies are taking these vast
databases of compounds and they're
profiling them
on various cellular assays and they get
in the order of tens of thousands of
hits
basically from these various compounds
it's then important to get more
information
on these hips and they use
systems like ghost green to essentially
understand
uh the the profile of the gene
expression that is actually coming
from that particular screen now other
customers have been interested in using
these arrays for
other applications such as studying
immunology
and inflammatory disease and we have
customers who are actually taking
patient derived cells
uh they're sorting the cells uh and then
they're profiling these cells in
cellular assays
uh again using different compounds but a
much smaller number of compounds
and these uh these types of studies can
basically help identify
uh responders and non non-responders as
well as patients who are undergoing some
type of adverse effect
and allows you to kind of go in and
study uh more importantly what's
happening
in these particular immunology
inflammation cell types
if you think of 12 different individuals
who might be
studied here you might sort those 12
patients out into
12 different sorted cells and you might
then take
each different sorted cell and profile
it with different compounds and so these
experiments can explode up into large
numbers
very very quickly and that's why this
high throughput system works very well
um the rad product that we have out is
actually being looked at
in terms of using it for toxicology
specifically mechanistic toxicology
and you can imagine that looking at
these gene expression profiles can
actually help you quickly identify
the toxicity mechanisms
that are happening in certain types of
uh uh events
uh within these animals that are being
tested um we've had people also contact
us about egg bio screening
uh and these model screening
applications as well
again the idea here is we're working
with tens of thousands of samples
and can provide up to 20 000 profiles at
a very low cost
now using gene expression profiles to
classify and stratify compounds
is actually something uh that has uh
been validated and understood for quite
some time
uh here's a paper that was actually uh
developed by a group
uh from bear scientific david work as
one of the authors on here
but they were one of the first people to
actually show that you can actually
train uh a a system
like this to develop a signature or
profile for these various compounds
and that allows you then to essentially
predict the response you might get or
the profile
you might get from new or novel
compounds
and this is quite valuable to be able to
actually
do this in some type of screening as
opposed to trying to develop this
and test in animals or or humans
obviously
so one of the main things we've had to
do to develop this system is to fit
essentially 20 000 genes
on a very tiny peg that we can put into
our high throughput system
the way we went about this was we
started with our our older systems
and looked at our clarium s and clarium
d platforms
uh here typically we're looking at
around 10 probes per gene and what you
see here on the right
is essentially a gene model there's many
different transcript isoforms that can
be spliced
in different ways and you can create
essentially a gene model looking at all
these different exons of this particular
gene
what we typically do is we would put
down the 10
best probes in various exons across this
gene model
to get essentially a summary of the gene
expression event that was happening here
for this gene
now to get a smaller uh chip
basically to reduce the cost what we've
done here is we focus the content on the
best
three probes and we've done this by
doing uh both
probe based selection uh using in silico
ranking
and and empirical probe selection using
real data
that we've accumulated over the years on
these various micro arrays
notice that we're also trying to target
probes in the most constitutive regions
here of the gene
so basically we're trying to get a gene
level estimate as opposed to trying to
understand the splicing
and the differences of the exons here
when we go and we look at the
performance in a classical latin square
study using spikes
we can compare this performance
essentially to our other products what
you see here is our clarium
s gene level product compared to the
human go screen products at both using
all 10 probes
and using the three probes that we've
selected and essentially
we get the same performance in terms of
sensitivity and specificity
now these pots that you're looking at
here these are called receiver operator
characteristic curves and again what
this is telling us is that we can
actually look
at a very low level event here this is
actually looking at one and a half
copies per cell versus three copies per
cell
on average in an rna sample okay and so
this is looking at a very low
differential expression change and what
you see here on the right panel are
those spikes
and you see a blue distribution of the
of the spikes this is the t
statistic or t test saying yes i see it
differentially expressed
versus everything else on the microarray
which is the null distribution it should
not be changing
that's all of the other genes that
aren't spikes this is a very nice way
for us to clearly look at
and and gauge essentially the
performance of these microarrays so
we've picked essentially the best three
probes and we achieve a performance
level
uh that we're satisfied with for these
types of applications
now if you ask how does this compare to
other technologies
uh like rna sequencing well we can
actually take
um the same rna samples that were used
during the microarray quality control
consortium
and were essentially applied to both
tacman and
rna sequencing and we can show that the
full change correlations are essentially
equivalent to what we get with these
other technologies
using purified rna so again we expect
these arrays to work
much like these other technologies and
being able to find
differentially expressed genes
now the clarium doe screen arrays also
contain
a lot of controls we have the ability to
look at this the general signal metrics
to make sure we're getting out
a good signal from the the genes we
expect to see expressed
we also have controls for the
hybridization
this is both the array and the scanning
controls and then we have target prep
controls which actually
make sure that the rna was in fact
purified
and or amplified correctly in addition
to that we have these very nice positive
negative controls these are actually
exon intron controls
and we expect to get good signal from
the exons obviously
and no signal from the introns if we
start to see signal from the introns
that means we're amplifying dna and that
rna
and that would be problematic so this is
a nice set of controls that we also have
on the array
um we have what we call anti-genomic
controls as well these are
probes that are used to estimate signal
background and can be
removed uh you help to remove the
background from
uh uh your probes during the pipeline
processing that happens
as i mentioned earlier we also have the
viral content on here for the human
genes
and we've included the ercc controls
that were made uh popular
during the microarray quality control
consortium
the good news is you don't really have
to worry about these controls because
your service provider
will look at these controls and use them
to make sure that the assay is working
correctly
and more importantly you can actually
analyze this data
in our software which is transcriptome
analysis console or we call this tac
we've designed this for investigators
although it's very sophisticated and a
lot of bioinformatics people
do use this um if you're not familiar
with this it's one of the biggest
advancements we've had
in our array portfolio it's free
it works with our new and older arrays
and basically it allows you to retain
that ownership of your data so that you
can actually analyze it
and get your results and move on uh much
quicker with your research
there's already over 600 literature
citations where they've published papers
essentially using the software and using
the figures that come out of the
software
and down below here you can see some
very nice figures
we have the principal component analysis
the differential expression analysis and
the ability to do things like
hierarchical clustering
uh if you're not familiar with this with
some of our other products you can also
do
micro rna association analysis as well
and pathway analysis
now when we're working specifically with
ghost green
what we're really trying to do is we're
trying to understand
what the transcriptome profile is for a
particular compound in a particular cell
type
and what i'm showing you here is
actually some real data
and then in the center uh the large pca
plot that you see here
there's actually uh six different
cell types that have essentially been
applied
uh with different compounds and
each one of these cell types essentially
um you can see kind of breaks off into
its separate
uh cluster meaning that that
transcriptome profile
is is somewhat similar within a
particular cell line
but if you then focus your analysis
within each cell line you can actually
see that different compounds
at different concentrations will
actually give you a differential
expression or a different transcriptome
profile and this is what basically
creates the signature essentially that
somebody can then
use to evaluate a new test compound
compared to
standards or known compounds that have
previously been run and if you look at
the top
left panel here you can see very clearly
if you focus on this dmso control it's
actually the blue that's over here in
the left
cluster along with two other compounds
and so
the dmso is the vehicle control to get
the compounds essentially into the cells
so in two of the compounds here we're
not getting much of a transcriptome
response here but you can see these
other three compounds are actually
giving us a very unique transcriptome
profile
characteristic of of those compounds
this is quite a powerful way
to essentially look at this data now
again
the beautiful thing about go screen is
that we're looking at 20
000 gene measurements and previous
technologies
if you're thinking about using things
like biospider
i think they use about 3500 different
gene expression profiles
or if you look at the l1000 technology
the
luminex bead technology that's only
looking at a thousand genes
here we're able to actually focus a
transcriptome profile on 20
000 genes and this is really the power
of of this particular
platform one thing i also want to
introduce you to
is something called dimensional
reduction algorithms
uh here's an example of uh some data
using something we call ega or
exploratory grouping analysis and this
comes in the tax software
what's nice about these dimensional
reduction algorithms
is that it goes and it looks for
clusters
of transcriptome profiles essentially so
it helps you build
essentially this structure of your data
and allows you to then find similarities
based on other things you know about the
compounds or other
responses that you've collected over the
course of your
your history doing any any type of
screening or clinical trials
uh this particular uh tool we're using
is called t stay
tuesday is quite popular these days it's
used for
all kinds of things for different for
looking at patterns in traffic
as well as internet usage patterns
and things like that so these are quite
powerful algorithms and when you can
take
20 000 pieces of information for every
compound and throw at these particular
algorithms it can be quite powerful
in finding associations um
just to be clear when we use these
different algorithms or incorporate them
in our software we always have an
advanced parameter
mode so if you're a bioinformatics
person out there
these tools although they're quite easy
for a normal person to use
you can also get quite sophisticated in
your analysis by using the advanced
parameters
that we've also made available
so originally a lot of this work was
done
using something called the connectivity
map or c
map and it's a it's a really brilliant
resource that was originally constructed
by the broad
which uses transcriptional expression
data to basically look at
all of these relationships between
diseases cell physiology and different
therapeutics and and these signatures
essentially are sitting there and and
can be used today
uh to essentially go and profile uh
compounds um
there's over 100 different cell types in
the database and there's over 27 000
different compound concentration
combinations that are in there
now this database was only generated
really across a thousand genes and these
were landmark genes
that were originally actually found on
microarrays
and thought to be a the best
representation
of of genes so basically to get the cost
down
they used this luminex bead technology
to profile a thousand genes here
and what's been found uh is that this
thousand genes
is was probably selected uh tailored
more for cancer
than for these other types of screens
and so the thought is is
what would happen if we actually go and
use 20 000 genes as opposed to just
a thousand genes however
this data resource still exists out
there
and people still want to leverage this
vast resource and so
if we want to we can actually go and try
to compare now
go screen data to cmap and the profiles
that are in cmap
now to be able to do that you want to
use what's called the level 5 c
map data and what i'm showing you here
is that you can actually take the
differences between the compounds
and the vehicle control in these screens
and these gene expression profile
differences
are actually very similar between the
two platforms and so
the triangles here actually represent uh
ghost green
um and this particular compound that's
highlighted here it's kind of the salmon
uh pink color here this is compound
ap7519
you can see that these profiles are all
clustered together here
and within this profile you're going to
there's different cell types which is
why you see the separation that you see
here
now there is some technical variance you
can see in the different platforms
however what's good here is that you can
still leverage and get some
estimation of what your compound looks
like relative to
the data that exists in cmap in fact
you can actually build a prediction
based on an enrichment scoring
technique and when we did this
with these six compounds across these
five different
cell types that you see at the top here
it turns out we could actually correctly
predict in most cases
the top prediction was both the correct
cell type and drug
in 16 out of the 34 cases using
this enrichment score
algorithm essentially now in some cases
um we didn't that wasn't
our our top hit was not the actual
compound
uh however it was um often
uh within the first two or three
compounds
um that we would uh uh uh
assay essentially um in terms of the
hits
um and then you have these other cases
where in fact you see the same mechanism
for a different compound that is
essentially known to have a
the same effect essentially by the same
mechanism
which essentially translates down to the
same pathway and that's what we see here
uh in this case with a persimmon tab
here
now if we um really want to talk about
screening it's really important to
understand
that we've enabled this particular
technology to work with direct lysates
and this is new for microarrays
typically we only work with purified rna
we've designed this platform to work
with something called
cells to signal which is a
commercially available direct lysis
solution basically it's already been
tested and works with a number of
different cell lines
most of our testing on this particular
platform is actually done
with gila and hep g2 lysates
and to understand how this works in your
lab
typically when you're running these
screens you're working with 96 well
plates
or or even smaller plates or in some
cases larger plates but the idea here is
that you want to
directly lyse these cells and to get a
good lysate that works with our assay
you want to make sure that you do an ice
cold pbs wash
on those cells and then what you want to
do is you want to basically target a
concentration of 100 cells per
microliter
using this lysis buffer the different
screens will have different
cells and the cells themselves would be
of different sizes
and so what we will typically do is
we'll work with the customer to
make sure ensure that this license
process is happening efficiently
with that customer but again the two
main important things
here are you want to make sure you do
this very cold pbs wash with the samples
to remove all the media
and then you want to target your lysis
solution on the cells
at about 100 cells per microliter
when you go and you actually uh send
your samples to the service provider
you're going to be sending them
uh probably in a 96 well plate if you're
already working in 384 well plates you
can do that as well
but we do request that you leave a
couple of walls blank so that we can add
some hela and liver rna controls and
these are batch processing controls
that allow us to see essentially what's
happening at the service provider
and when we talk about actually working
with a partner such as yourself
typically we go through these different
phases there's a pilot phase
here's again where we like to determine
that the cell line is actually working
with the lysis
under the right conditions in some cases
we might actually
do a second dilution in the lysis buffer
um and we might also adjust the ampli
amplification cycles that we're actually
using
should we be working with some very
different
type of cell this allows us to ensure
basically that everything is working
well up front then typically there'll be
a small
pop study where the customer will will
run
known compounds with known effects so
that we can uh basically demonstrate
uh the effectiveness of these
transcriptome profiles and we do all of
this again
ahead of the full screen and again these
screens can be quite large we're talking
uh in order of 10 uh to 40 000
samples in a screen um and that allows
us essentially to get down to
these very low cost price points
now we've partnered essentially this
service offering with ibx
here in the united states this is
formerly known as redcore
or or this was uh the rutgers
service uh provider they've recently
changed their name uh
to infinity biologics ibx uh however and
they are
in uh in new jersey uh so in the united
states this is your
primary service provider uh and if
you're
listening to this recording from europe
uh we've partnered
with eurofins uh formerly known as
aerosupplied biotechnology out of
denmark now both of these groups
uh we've worked with quite extensively
um and we really value their
participation in this platform because
they've been
uh really great partners and generate
really high quality data
what uh typically a customer will do is
they'll actually order this
lysis buffer and then they will
work with us and send essentially their
samples
to these service providers uh who will
then buy the arrays and the chips
and and and run the actual service
so with that i will thank you for your
attention and take any questions
thank you so much anthony for that
outstanding presentation we're going to
go ahead and move into the live q a
but we are running on short on time so
we'll probably only have time for that
one question
so the first one i have here is when
compared to the alternative screening
platforms like
rna-seq why is go screen the best choice
for research
maggie thinks that's a that's a fairly
common question we get and
the answer is is twofold one is cost
and quite simply even though the cost of
bulk rna sequencing has come down
quite a bit the cost of doing library
construction
especially thinking about doing library
construction across tens of thousands of
samples
is quite prohibitive the other thing is
that we're still working with rna which
means you need
dynamic range you need to make sure that
these signals or these profiles that you
get
if you're measuring uh gene x in in one
transcriptome profile it might be
represented 10 000 times
where gene y might be there five times
and then in another sample
gene x and gene y might be there five
times uh
for for both genes and so the the number
of reads you need to see those genes can
change quite a bit and so
you need a minimum depth essentially to
see
those gene expression profiles
and when you put all of that together
across 20 000 genes
and try to do it with sequencing that
depth becomes quite prohibitive
now if you try to target it with panels
first of all it's quite difficult to put
together panels of that size of 20 000
but more importantly across these large
screens
if you're building databases across time
it becomes prohibitive because these
these panels that you build have
variation to them
uh in their manufacturing and so you'll
have dropouts and things like that that
happen
what's nice about microarrays is that
semiconductor technology
creates essentially the same microarray
every time so it's really great for
these studies
uh that that go on uh for long periods
of time that that basically
are building uh databases so it allows
you to directly measure
uh all of these 20 000 events on every
single chip
you don't have to worry about drop out
thanks so much anthony and thank you to
everyone in the audience for the great
questions today
as we have run out of time just a
reminder any questions you did submit
that were not answered will be addressed
via email
and don't miss out on all of our other
valuable presentations as part of this
virtual event you can visit the agenda
tab in the auditorium for
full listing to receive more information
about the new clarium ghost green essay
please visit our microarray analysis
booth in the exhibit hall
the poster hall to see ghost screen
posters or click on the red request more
information button throughout the
virtual event
lastly this presentation will be
available for on-demand viewing through
september 30th 2021.
please share it with a colleague who
might be interested thank you all again
for your participation
until next time goodbye